617 830 4750 is the number let's take
our next caller from the 309 area code
caller what is your name and where are
you calling from oh yeah hi this is Eric
I'm calling from Galesburg Illinois
awesome what's on your mind today um
well um you know this wikileaks release
that happened yesterday hmm has started
being reported on in the press and I've
noticed at least some you know my
Twitter this continuation of of a theme
of Julian Assange being a puppet or a
pawn of the Russians and it seems that
every time the information is released
the media and especially curiously
liberals lately have been spinning
spinning it as Julian Assange and
WikiLeaks is essentially a an arm of the
Russian intelligence yeah so let's pause
right there I'm glad you're bringing
this up there is a wing of people that
believe drawing any timing connection
between the growing scandal of Trump and
Russia and oh look at these releases the
vault seven WikiLeaks releases which if
you look at the details are not really
providing new information they're really
just providing their leaking specific
sources of mostly already known
information the conspiratorial mind
would say it's deliberately time to take
attention away from what is the bursting
scandal involving jeff Sessions michael
Flynn Trump met with the Russian
ambassador etc etc etc uh you know I
don't know I see that I'm seeing the
same timing and I can't i if I'm
completely honest yes it's weird to me
as well and numerous people you know are
comments we know that there are a number
of
propaganda nated online propaganda
commenting efforts it's widely known and
over the last few days our youtube
channel is just riddled with comments
about talk about the vault 7 wikileaks
thing and my sense is that some people
in our audience genuinely want us to
talk about that but that there's clearly
an effort here to just constantly talk
about it to take attention away from
other issues that are going on yeah and
you know interesting relation to this to
the jeff Sessions thing for me
personally the fact that he met with
Russian officials is no big deal right
but he lied about it right right right
and i think that the political tax
that's being taken by the democrats
generally speaking is to really focus on
the russia angle of the of this whole
thing rather than going after policy
specifics maybe it just makes more
political sub to do it if the one-liner
but i think that it's a very dangerous
sort of path to go down and it
undermines the more legitimate arguments
that can be made of and i think i see
the whole thing with julian assange and
wikileaks and because you know the
Democrats got but her odd due to the
Podesta emails and the DNC yeah but the
truth is looking at males themselves are
a tiny fraction of what i would call the
broader russia story and i said this
before so you know i agree with you that
democrats are probably not generally
playing this thing in the best way but i
don't believe that it's accurate to
minimize the importance of the russia
story i think the Podesta leaks now are
a tiny fraction of what's going on but i
think that you need to pursue an
all-of-the-above strategy which we've
been trying to do which is we're
reporting on the russia stuff but we're
also reporting on the crazy stuff that
Republicans in the House and Senate are
passing and you've got it you've got to
pursue an all-of-the-above approach yeah
I think that is a good approach to take
and just one more thing on the the kind
of content of this vaults of stuff it's
true similarly to
the Snowden revelations that you know to
the kind of you know inteligencia people
who follow this sort of stuff it was no
great rebel there's no great revelations
here you know we know that this kind of
hacking happens yes but it's the
specificity and the nuance and if you
read between the lines and the culture
of the whole thing and how that can be
then abused bringing it out into the
light even though it's like well we
already knew this stuff I think really
has an important isn't is important and
more information for me personally is
almost always better unless it's you
know that you know operational details
or the new codes or something like that
no doubt I don't disagree with you I'm
for more information but when it comes a
potentially time in a way to distract
from what are what are issues I question
the timing of it but I can't disagree
with anything you've said appreciate the
call I've got to move on always great to
hear from you hope to hear from you
again soon